it may not be illegal but I mean he went
on The View talking about Hunter Biden
and Joe Biden corruption and barisma and
all that and they they kind of make
sense here this is weird and this shows
you that the system is not impervious
watch this this is going to blow your
mind like there's a even Anna Navarro
I'm leading too much just watch
it it has an appearance of in front as a
matter of fact that this is a little
piece of personal trivia I believe I am
the only White House reporter who asked
about Hunter Biden and barisma during
the Obama administration because as soon
as that deal was announced that he was
going on the board of barisma he was
going to be paid about 50
000 a month I I went and I asked Jay
Carney who was then the White House
Press Secretary I said isn't you know
his father was the vice president and
he's in charge of Ukraine policy you
know isn't that at the very least
unseemly it may not be illegal but I
mean so so he said well you know this he
gave me basically a non-answer saying
that that the the vice president had
nothing to do with this yeah
um and that you know Hunter Biden's
going to do what Hunter Biden's gonna be
and it got reviewed by the state
department didn't it yeah and approved
which I think I shouldn't have I mean I
mean look it you can say this looks like
what like sleazy it doesn't look right
but the question is is there anything
illegal and is there any evidence
whatsoever that Joe Biden actually took
part of
okay I am telling you mark my words they
are getting rid of Joe Biden and the
fact that ABC News just put on one of
their main guys right to go on The View
to discuss that why else would you put
him on they're trying to show you that
something is there so that he will step
down again he's not going to be
impeached because they don't have the
Senate but they're trying to show him
the door otherwise it make why would you
bring on you have to understand these
are highly produced shows they pick when
they are going to have someone on and
exactly what they are going to say he
knows and the producers know what he's
going to say there so he says I know
he's like look at me I was one of the
first guys to say that there was
something there was something going on
here in Jay Carney who was the Press
Secretary of the time he was the cringe
Jean-Pierre of his day he just kind of
blew it off but obviously something was
there and then even freaking Anna
Navarro when they're like oh they passed
it through the state department the
state department said it was fine
meaning that Hunter had this job and Joe
is the vice president and it made no
sense because he was a crack addict and
why should a crack addict be working at
a Ukrainian Energy company even Anna
Navarro's like that shouldn't have
happened so they're admitting the view
just platformed and a newsman to say
something's rotten in stink town and
then they agreed with it they agreed
with it
foreign